SPEAKER: In this
"BigQuery Spotlight,"
we'll be going over all
sorts of useful ways
to work with data in BigQuery.
A great way to learn is by
doing, so in this episode,
we'll show you how to get
started with a BigQuery
sandbox.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BigQuery sandbox
gives you free access
to try out BigQuery
and use the UI
without providing a credit card
or using a billing account.
It's a quick way to
get started and try out
some of the concepts we'll be
talking about in this series.
To get started, click on the
link in the description below.
If you're a new
Google Cloud user,
you'll need to create
an account and a project
by following the prompts.
Once a project is
created, you'll
be redirected to the
BigQuery console, where
you'll see Sandbox in
the top left-hand corner.
If you're returning
Google Cloud user,
create a new project by
selecting the Project dropdown.
Your new project may be created
with a default billing account.
If that's the case, go into the
Billing Account Management page
and select Disable Billing by
following the instructions also
linked below.
Then use the search
bar within the console
to head to BigQuery.
Make sure your new project
is selected in the Project
dropdown, and
there, you will also
see Sandbox in the
top left-hand corner.
Now that you're in
the BigQuery Sandbox,
you're ready to start querying.
That's all it takes
to get set up.
Because you aren't charged for
using the BigQuery Sandbox,
there are a few caveats.
Mainly, any tables or
views that you create
will expire after 60 days.
You're also limited to
10 gigabytes of storage,
and one terabyte of
data process each month.
Still a lot of room
to play around with.
These numbers may change, so be
sure to check the documentation
for the latest information.
Other than that,
you can easily start
working with public data sets,
loading in your own data,
and running some queries.
BigQuery provides publicly
available data sets for anyone
to analyze covering a
variety of data types,
from historical weather to taxi
trips taken in New York City.
To analyze public
data, just click
on the Add Data button
on the left-hand side
to see a list of the
publicly available data
sets that you already
have available.
As a quick example,
let's use the project
sunroof public data set, so
you can see how much sunlight
hits your roof in a year.
In this sample query,
we're averaging
the amount of
sunlight per US state,
and ordering the top three
states by the highest sunlight
potential.
As you can see, the
top three states
are New Mexico,
Arizona and Nevada.
That's a lot of sunshine.
Don't worry if you're not
sure how we built this query.
In the next episode, we'll
explain this in more detail
and break down how
to query your data.
Look out for the next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight,"
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]